hey how's it going my name is welcome
back to stray cat crossing I love this
game if you haven't watched the other
two episodes go ahead you I bet you have
you're a you're a good good bro
sounds good to say alright so we're
gonna keep playing doing good though
less off we fed our best friend to a
witch and now what we need to do is go
this might be very confusing I
understand but we need to talk to this
owl hoot hoot was the time what will the
time be if it needs to be there tea time
of course of course is tea time now
we'll go to the wolves
and we will tell the wolves that the
spell is broken and that way we can save
this man who says that we are ugly the
story makes sense
all right I promise you okay hey Wolf's
see your each wolf represented season
it's very romantic
Becky did you take to fix faith clearly
she didn't anybody messes with his
things and gets back in impatient
waiting yeah we hate yet gonna get his
NER sitting pretty one piece actually
she gave me a scroll to remove your
curse city with it
hey you did get kid I always believed in
her bull [ __ ] now set a three a hen all
right all right we'll let the grub go
but only after you said it
Shh I don't know should be I guess I
don't see why I wouldn't trust these
[ __ ] please don't kill me
whoa famine pestilence and death death
four horsemen shut full yeah part and
set yeah free and to there fart fate yet
death serve okay
this is some animal [ __ ] going on here
Savalas must know better say goodbye to
the seasons what what does that mean
that blessed sphinx oh [ __ ]
you you did this to it oh my god another
chance
hurry up forget me loose ha ha ha ha
sucker Oh for [ __ ] sake
god damn it I'm sorry guys
can I talk to them yeah did this I'm
sorry that Sphinx I get it if the last
thing I do fine
all right well we're gonna go something
is bad to happen I feel a little weird
yep
save juice juice don't look good now you
have to leave now hurry before she camps
okay I'm gonna go thank you
all right think it's up oh god what is
that
ah whatever left is cocoon sure made a
mess oh god there's a key inside
if I learn anything from a game is that
if there's a key you better [ __ ] pick
it up
oh god that means we can leave now
Oh God can we please yes Kat do they see
Kat they say they miss you what does
that mean
Oh God are you Kat
no that's right you don't look like had
a dog cat why did you leave they wanted
to hold you they loved you very much
they loved you very much Kat where are
you well good talk
I'm gonna bounce the key fits even if
you look a little different I hope that
I don't look so different to you over
there she is
you have a lot of explaining to do later
make sure you take good care of it it's
a very important scarf by the way what's
your name yeah what is my name I didn't
say it great what's your name my name
what's your name
oh I knew it
nice to meet you Kat let's take you home
but what was that that was really weird
need to get that scarf I'm [ __ ]
welcome use so this is my house well
well well
tell me something hey Nicky how did why
did I even say I was something she would
say something alright there should be
footprints going upstairs yeah they're
going this way okay this is really
[ __ ] creepy
alright what do we got
the Attic a new area oh my god what is
that uh hello
oh my scarf you're giving it to me
great thanks buddy
thank you it's a magical scarf
what was that if you wear it you'll
always be warm and safe beautiful was
that you just like when you're with your
dear old Benjamin
who are you
please please remember
who was that
okay we're in a new place
everyone is here and they're now showing
stray cat crossing how convenient
what the [ __ ] the Sphinx she's so nice
what you look so sad I ship them now
Benjamin's chillin put on the strangest
place Benjamin's children popcorn get
your popcorn for only three pennies at
this table man sure I don't have three
pennies he is like [ __ ] Pokemon over
again and purge it play escaping boy I'm
the dormouse f dou F Mouse Bravo
ain't no bloke getting past me without a
ticket
what set you ain't got no ticket then
you ain't getting past the door mess ya
[ __ ] dormouse alright let's get a
ticket Wow [ __ ] sake someone is bound
to have a ticket here I don't want to
watch Benjamin well then sir I think it
likes me we can do a save maybe she sa
okay how are we gonna get in okay we can
go back here maybe we can find a ticket
in one of these caskets Sebastian Melton
all right let's look if there's a
Benjamin are there old artists it won't
budge huh that's a roach inside okay all
right so we give him the rose with the
roach make her happy
thank you here take this is it a ticket
yes can't wait to see the cinema you
never know what's gonna happen next in
this game that's why I like it so much
all right we can go in ha ha ha you
wherever you be sorry the actor have
some nerves you don't know that
everyone's been looking for you
oh I'm in the play what are you doing
just standing there you're in in five
minutes to the stage chop-chop
okay we're going to state yes the story
takes place long at her 20 years to be
exact it is a tale of rue and rule and
this is the first act - stage
hahahaha what is this I have to buy a
ticket to be in my own show this is Kat
she's five years old
sorry
you
I'm not sure if I look five cat I am
your mother
time for bed cat cat would you like to
hear a bedtime story
ahem
cat would you like to hear a bedtime
story what if we say no I'll go with it
I would like to hear one here how about
a story about a mother sheep and her son
yep yes okay
once upon a time there was the mother
sheep and her RAM son this was mommy's
favorite story but one day a pack of
wolves came and ate her son Oh mother
she was very sad but also relieved
the end
we will now break for a short
information good play there's nothing
this way what about this way well it
looks like there's something here Oh God
no more basements what the actual [ __ ]
am I looking at
oh no I lost it Benjamin is gonna be mad
Oh what did you lose exactly Oh all the
rehearsing has been made me real hungry
you have anything I could eat the eggs
no thanks I'll eat sweets can't believe
we still have the egg tell me that I'm
beautiful oh you're you're beautiful yes
you look great I know I don't need you
to tell me that I want some popcorn ow
but I can't tell the players over I wish
I had some now though have you seen her
brother went to collect eggs a long time
ago I have an egg no no go ahead take
the egg I know he wouldn't fail us we're
going to make a cake
yes that's what everyone does between
place can you come by later okay if I
want some all right okay great audience
by the way it says how did it go the
Sphinx she's so nice but she looks so
sad I wonder if it's because she doesn't
like a roses yep that's it
I'm sure I sure miss my dad as a door
there
okay I see it what is this
hello
I can't talk to it hey hey nice a
musical monkey why does it look so
frightened it's old house I've seen this
before
all right well let's go back I guess
there's a small coin inside penny oh
great Kendall all right let's look for
two more coins then crystal
crystal spawn what Sydney did you like
to play is sat inside a swan
oh yeah he likes Mons of course can I
can I have it can't I
yes wow you're the best so unrooted
oh I I don't know who I could be thanks
for the favor hey take this whoo we got
a key
yeah I can't go inside the ticket booth
had a ball Magi man won't let me in
ever since the cat ran away act 2 is
about to give again please make your way
to your seat I love the music it's so
good
let's keep this play going whatever the
[ __ ] it is I don't know man
Oh God you where have you been hi sorry
the actors have some nerve don't you
know that everyone's been looking for
you really you have they what are you
doing your Saturday you're on in five
minutes to the stage cha cha
this is cat cat are you excited about
having little brothers ahem cat are you
excited about having little brothers yes
of course you are it's only natural
please go and tell everyone
tell them what
add is a Dorf the twins are coming this
might be difficult to stay everything
will be better when we move mother
the city is wonderful I always it's
always summer here there sorry
say goodbye to the seasons Oh
Benjamin what about the house the house
the house is just a memory Benjamin I
don't want to leave
I like the seasons I don't want to leave
them behind
but mother the twins are coming why are
you so selfish why are you always so
selfish what does your family mean to
you Benjamin
what's that the door cat
where is cat
you
all of this fighting between mommy and
Benny makes cat very sad and so cat
decides to run away
what happens now I don't know
we lost the rest of the script the end
breasts I'm gonna have to end that
episode there I'm sorry I'll see you in
the next one it will probably be the
last one all right
thank you for watching stay awesome
you